[Music]
all right the countdown continues and
look at that 33 and 32
same logo not a typo teddy bridgewater
drew lock now teammates competing
to be the starting quarterback unless
and until the broncos trade for aaron
rodgers
assuming that doesn't happen does the
fact chris that you have
teddy one spot ahead of drew is that
your indication that teddy should be the
starter i i
favor him more right now you know my
list is done as right now right this is
the top 40 quarterbacks as i see it
going to the 2021 season
everybody's on the same team and this is
really my
depth chart at the position that's
basically what it is
i got a 40-man depth chart and yeah as i
sit here right now
i trust teddy bridgewater more than i do
drew lock drew lock has more potential
and big time talent there's no doubt
about that
and there's a lot to like about drew
lock we've talked about it a lot mike
i mean big arm pretty good athlete we've
seen some moments that i think you and i
on sunday have watched and went wow
that's
those are some damn good throws and
plays and all of that
but he's got a little bit of that brett
favre gunslinger
i can fit it in there no matter what no
matter how small the hole is
i'm going to be aggressive and do those
type of things that he's got to knock
out of his game and that's where teddy
bridgewater
has a great advantage over drew lock you
know teddy bridgewater
you know mike is the old phrase of yeah
he's not going to win your games but
he's not going to lose you any either
drew lock he can lose you some games
right now
but he's got the potential to be a guy
that can do some extraordinary things
and win some football games too
so hopefully all this hey met with
peyton manning in the off season
he's i'm sure watched himself on film a
lot and realizes
he's just got to change his approach and
style a little bit if he wants to
survive in the league and be a starter
and be a star one day in the league
yeah and look he's only got two years in
the nfl
injuries have been an issue and this is
a situation where the light can come on
but if it's going to come on it's got to
come on soon this is his chance yeah
they brought in the guy to compete with
him
the aaron rodgers rumors are continuing
to loom and they'll
if if there's no trade and there likely
won't be it's still going to be
something that's on the table for next
year if locke
wants this job if he wants to stay with
the broncos if he wants to become the
guy there
this is the time that he's got to step
it up and he's got to use that presence
of teddy bridgewater
as the impetus to reach that higher
level you had drew lock at 25 last year
teddy at 29 so they're both down
yeah and maybe that competition will
cause one of them
to emerge i think it's good for the
broncos to have two guys who are so
closely matched yes
because you you you assume you hope you
pray that one of them is going to access
a higher level of performance because of
that competition definitely definitely
like so closely matched and have
opposite playing styles that i think
maybe could wear off on either guy a
little bit
like teddy bridgewater i'd go he needs
to look at drew lock and go i could can
i take some of that
over aggressiveness you have and give it
to me
to where i could you know push the ball
down the field and take a few more
chances
that's one of the negative things about
him at times you know but
it is vic fangio a defensive coach they
do have a good defense there
bradley chubb is you know
and von miller should be back in the
fold as that duo this year everything
looks good from that standpoint
but they have insurance for kind of
either way
of how this goes and yeah i give
bridgewater the
advantage right now because of yes
taking care of the football more
experience
not losing games but drew lock is one of
those guys on this list that could make
a considerable jump and i would also say
if drew lock can show during training
camp in preseason that he's really
he's got the offense and all of those
things
he is the guy that can maximize i think
their talent on their offensive side of
the ball the most but it's an if
it's a big if we gotta see you know
there's no excuse for either one of
these quarterbacks whoever starts in
denver because
as we've mentioned a lot over the last
14 15 months
denver stacked on offense they're
stacked and it's year two with patch
shermer the o line's good the tight end
is good
and the wide receiving core is as good
as any in football so
they got to get better results of the
quarterback to help their team out
put that graphic back up please kristen
the odds provided by points bet sports
book
for the quarterback to take the first
snap yeah the exact same odds plus 140
for loch and bridgewater
then there's brett ripping at plus 2000
in between
other yeah plus 220 plus 220
is not that much far from farther from
plus 140.
other is aaron rodgers right yeah he's
in other aaron rodriguez or deshaun
watson maybe i guess yeah but yeah
one of those two right other is aaron
rodgers or
desean watson and yeah i think there's
still a lot of people in the nfl that
think denver has their
their eye on that situation so there
there's no doubt about it
so we'll see they got a good team they
need the quarterbacks to show up
other can be anyone other can be chris
sims yeah well those odds would be a
whole lot longer
it could be brock osweiler but you're
still in other i'm in
other other is anyone yes billions of
people
are i always say take the field other
has the field of the entire world
other than loch bridgewater and ripon
all right jared goff
down from 24 which some
viewed as a dis a slight an insult last
year
he's down to 31 and those folks who
thought it was an insult to be at 24
president yeah 31 hey
right now 31 for jared goff is probably
the right spot
chris i look i i i
still love the fact that the rams felt
compelled to tuck
goff into the matthew stafford trade so
maybe the boss won't realize
that we're giving up a first round pick
to get this horrible contract off the
books
they never we've been down this road
yeah they never should have done it
the guy has i don't know that regressed
is the right word because
i i i i don't think it was him
in 2018 when they were a super bowl team
it was todd gurley
it was brandon cooks it was robert woods
it was cooper cup
jared goff was just the guy who pulled
it all together
um is he going to be able to have any
remote degree of success do you believe
with the lions this year without the
quality of weapons around him that he's
enjoyed in l.a you're right i mean you
know
sean mcvay so i mean yeah there's a lot
of questions there i think and i think
that jared goff
is yeah hanging on to being a starting
quarterback by a thread
you know there's things to like about
his game i know that he is tough i'm
gonna give him that
he's played a lot of big football games
so he's got the moxie of not being you
know intimidated by any of that either
but there's issues with this game you
know they're all around
you know and i i'm a guy that like
listen i i give
experience like you know a real thought
and it helps in my rankings and i
understand he has some experience
but for a guy that's played in the nfl
for five years
he doesn't show that type of experience
when you watch him on film or do things
like that
there is a you know a a
a lack of awareness of situational
football at times
and what to do you know he can have
moments of being a poor thrower
he throws a very uncatchable ball just
like we showed on some of those
highlights there it's a knuckle that
doesn't spin hard
and it wobbles those are hard to catch
he's not the greatest within the pocket
he's not good at all within the pocket
actually with moving in there
and then of course extending plays or
scrambling is not one of his things
either
he does have a strong arm you know he
does know how to be a leader to a
certain extent but not going to have a
great
presence there so that's where i'm on
the fence with with a guy like jared
goff
i have some guys yeah that of course
haven't played it down in the nfl yet
that are going to be in front of him
but that's where i look at it and go hey
talent not great for jared goff
and the fact that he has the experience
and stuff it doesn't really
show all that much hey he's running the
third and one bootleg
out to the right you know and he throws
a ball 15 yards down the field into
double coverage and you go what you
could have just ran for
four yards and got the first down and we
keep going why did you do that there's
too much stuff like that
constantly or it's a defensive struggle
the game
and all of a sudden he throws a ball
into double coverage against the jets or
makes an errant throw to go like wait
this is not the right time to make that
throw or do those type of things and
that's where
he's a little confusing to me as an
evaluator
the other options on the roster because
you said that
jared goff is hanging on to a starting
job by a thread
the problem is yeah tim boyle
and david b-l-o-u-g-h it's either blau
or blow or block blouse i think
well of the three options bla that's
right it's the blood king
though i forgot about the blood king
david blau how could i forget
but again between blah blah and black
he's
but but uh nevertheless who's who
they're gonna bench him no you're
safe right they didn't draft anybody
unless they bring someone in
via trade or free agency there's no way
goff's in trouble this year
no i don't think so either no we heard
the rumors that there might have been
some interest in
you know the quarterback with that top
10 pick and all that i think he was very
relieved
he said that after the draft that it you
know it felt good and it showed the team
had confidence in him and those type of
things
and i understand them going with jared
goff they're in a rebuild here
the detroit lions so they're they're
they
they you know paying the guy a little
bit and doing that
he has won some football games they're
going to get their team in order before
you know maybe they address the
quarterback situation or they just want
to see what he has
you know i think brad holmes might have
some belief in the guy that maybe he can
turn things around and all that type of
stuff
so that's where he can go he's been
there he's done that he's won some
football games
uh but the the but and he's tough
but the bottom line is the rams were
trying to bench him and not play him for
john walford
we can't forget that aspect they thought
that's almost as bad as being
benched for david black well that's what
i mean so that tells you a little bit
too
and you asked i talked about like i
don't know if he's regressed i would
argue yes and ways
yes i think he has regressed from two or
three years ago so
uh this is a big year for jared goff if
he wants to continue to be a starting
quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports